good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast this is a very live no
not live sorry very special episode of
the toast because we are podcasting from
the desert that's right desert toast and
I'm sitting down with our fifth and
final episode of the week with somebody
whom I adore somebody whom I respect
somebody who I also just hate because
she's so beautiful it's Shannon hey
Shannon Ford how are you hi Claude how
you doing turds turds is doing good
turds is so excited to be shitty
[__] well well oh well we'll talk
about that turds was [__] I am excited
to be sitting down with Shannon but I
like to call her manin because I spent
the day traveling with Shannon yesterday
and you learned so much about people
when
you travel with them and what I learned
is like Shannon you are low-key a man
you are Manon you are a beast like the
way you hustle and you hoist bags and
you're just like strong wow okay I feel
like that's very unsuspecting of me so I
I'm gonna stick with that nickname I
wasn't expecting and I don't mean that
in any sort of derogatory way about your
looks because you know how I feel about
you no thank you absolutely stunning
um but you are a man okay I'm I'm I feel
like I'm gonna accept that willingly and
graciously because I've been working out
so by the way you're jacked object
Shannon sent me pictures of her
Stagecoach outfits and I literally
didn't know who that was your arms like
you're so toned because it sounds scary
you're now like madly in love with a
personal trainer yeah it does come with
it it's pros and cons the pros are that
you get to work out and become strong
and the cons are that you have to work
out I know I don't think I could ever be
like in a relationship with somebody who
is like he's a professional Fitness
expert he doesn't like force me or
anything but it's just one of those
things where if he's going every day
it's like such a slop Kebab if I don't
go with him of course you know so so
Shannon and I are in the desert we're
headed to see age coach actually today
is day one we woke up at the ass
[__] crack of dawn because
we're on obviously La time but I thought
I was going to sleep till noon given the
day I had yesterday also we went to bed
at 9 30. we went to bed at 9 30 and I
and I was which is beautiful I was
deeply unwell let me let me just without
being too graphic tell everyone what my
day was like I I do on eBay Graphics I
want you to know that when she was
telling us a story I go can you include
as many details oh my God I am Manning
you are oh I wanted all the details okay
go ahead and Jackie doesn't really like
on the podcast when I talk about like
poop and stuff so I'm feeling like she's
not here she's not here to tell us no
Shannon listen up Jackie so we flew into
La yesterday and when we landed in L.A
we drove to Palm Springs about two hour
drive and when I woke up on Thursday
morning you know I had a little tickle
in my throat I wasn't feeling 100 now in
retrospect it really wasn't that big of
a deal but maybe some tea maybe some tea
and like just drink water you know maybe
a vitamin C or whatever yeah but in the
moment I was like [__] I'm getting sick
so oh I called in a z-pack when we
landed in Palm Springs I picked up the
z-pack I took the first two doses right
when we got in the car and I went on my
Merry way we did errands we went to the
grocery store we picked up liquor we
picked up our Festival tickets and while
we were picking up our Festival tickets
we were driving to the like location
where you pick up the tickets and you
know something hit me I also need you to
explain when you pick up the tickets so
it's obviously 102 degrees it's a real
number of the temperature that it is
outside when you pick up the tickets you
do have to like walk of good ways
obviously if you're feeling bright and
dandy it's not that big of a deal it's
just like hot as [__] and then you're
walking and like standing in the sun to
like wait in line to your ticket so it's
a really it's a low-key miserable
experience so just know that and then
couple it with this with what I was
dealing with so as we're pulling up I'm
like I literally say to Shannon we had a
plastic bag I'm like please pass me that
plastic bag I feel like I'm gonna vomit
in the back of this car and I was like
oh maybe I'm in the back of the car I
should sit in the front next time maybe
I'm getting car sick and then it just
proceeded to go so downhill from there
and I really won't I will spare you all
the details but what I learned was that
you are not supposed to take a z-pack on
an empty stomach I did not know that and
I certainly didn't know I was not
supposed to take two doses because the
first dose you do have to take two pills
right so it's the heaviest 500
milligrams like yeah
it was let me just say this a long drive
home we had a 20-minute drive from the
festival pickup location back to our
rental house and I will say that the
whole car ride was probably one of the
lowest moments of my life am I allowed
to say that you were fighting for your
life in the porta potty I was fighting
for my life in the porta potty I was
fighting for my life in the car I was
fighting for my life when I finally got
home like it was a long afternoon at one
point I did try to offer like a molecule
of comfort and I was like it's okay
Claude just breathed like we're so close
and she immediately goes we're not we're
seven minutes away I'm watching the maps
I was sitting in the [__] front seat
I saw the GPS like it literally we were
eight minutes away I'll never forget our
time to arrive was 3 41 and it was 3
[__] 33. the time would not move and
it was one thing like if I was gonna
throw up I don't care I'll [__] throw
up on the side of the road it was the
other end you guys it wasn't notovirus
2.0 because it wasn't even close to what
I experienced when I had the notavirus
but it was
it was tough for everyone involved we
all do it's also hard for me to like
know that Shannon was seeing me like
this shut up because I like I think the
world of you Shannon and I want you to
like I want you to think I'm like
fabulous and Fabulous Girls just don't
crap their pants remember we were in the
kitchen and you were like I just really
appreciate you being so sweet and
comforting Margo's like what about me no
everyone was so nice and like Shannon
was so helpful she as I was like
literally on the verge of crapping my
pants she was on the phone with this IV
company she was like we'll get you an IV
tonight when you're all you know
depleted will replenish you and it was
just so grateful because I was like so
focused on myself and then afterwards I
was like was I being okay in the car oh
you're being so fine you're about to
[__] your pants it was humility guys it
was really humiliating and so I we went
all of that to say we went to bed at
literally 9 30. it had been a long day
it's been a long day and it was honestly
you know what we all wanted the IVs
anyways we all benefited from you almost
[__] in your pants don't feel bad and we
had some lovely lovely nurses one of
them was an emergency medic and he was
like you took 500 milligrams of
azithromy he was literally shook he was
he was like are you okay okay yeah he
was like you good and I was like no sir
I'm not I'm not good I haven't been good
for a while I'm so glad you're here so
glad you're here so we're replenished
stomach is not 100 I'd be lying if I
said it was but I'm not gonna let it get
in the way because Stagecoach is the
best weekend of the year we got Luke
Bryan we got Chris Stapleton we've got
Kane Brown we've got Old Dominion we've
got so many good performances so many
good ones I'm so excited we have such
cute outfits we're gonna make so many
tick tocks so the trip was I was not
gonna lie last night I was really
thinking I'm like you know what if I
pulled all my savings I could get myself
a jet and just get [__] out of here I
was like I can't do this all weekend I
knew you were so serious that's another
reason selfishly that we were trying to
make sure you're okay because I was like
claw can't leave church can't go I was
gonna leave I know you are Margaret said
you would I was gonna leave because if
you knew how low I was feeling Shannon
you would you would have threw me on the
plane myself I'm I'm the same as you I
would rather need to throw up than [__]
duh you know I hate throwing up but the
thing with throwing arms like you really
do it anywhere in a garbage can well the
thing about it is it just happens really
quickly and then it's done the the neck
the other one is just it's more of a
process I feel like yeah
um anyways so Jackie if you're listening
to this I truly apologize for going
there but I did what I had to do and I'm
better that's all that matters yeah so
if you guys um are not following me in
China on Instagram like we're gonna be
posting and Tick Tock of course what are
you doing with your life what are you
doing with life we're gonna be making
such fire content we look like [__]
rats right now because it's 8 30 in the
morning and we've been we've been up
since 5 30. actually let me take that
back speak for yourself I look like a
rat
I am wearing okay let me just let me
paint a picture for you guys last night
I'm not doing well you know I'm I'm in
the post sickness era you know post
coital and I text Shannon because we're
all like going to bed I'm like you want
to come and watch TV with me in my room
she's like yeah so I come here I'm
wearing uh you know
six pajamas they're from Tommy John a
toast sponsor they're blue um lawn
sleeve and and of course and joggers
they're they're not like the sexiest
things ever but like I'm literally in a
house with Shannon and Margo Emily and
Kyle like who the [__] am I trying to
impress Fair Shannon rolls in here and
I'm like oh my God I think Shannon is
trying to [__] she's wearing this like
Silk negligee that is a matching robe
and it's very like low-cut and I just um
I'm honestly confused if I'm being
completely honest listen I'm in a
long-distance relationship sometimes a
girl just gets 100 I understand
um so I was just having this
conversation with Claude outside as she
was low-key roasting me for my uh pajama
choices because then we went outside and
Emily's like wearing literally like
sweatpants and a white T-shirt and she's
like what are you wearing Shannon I'm
like yeah what are you wearing so I've
always dressed like this like even when
I was in high school in college my
friends would be like why the [__] are
you wearing that and I just genuinely
like wearing their little slips like
little silk slips from wherever you know
like yeah probably Victoria's Secret and
other places like that right and then
it's like a little sheer rope that I put
over it because I didn't want to be a
little
um [__] and walk around the house in a
you know silk little necklace so anyways
I put a robe over it and yes it does
look like
um I'm trying to impress someone with my
sleep attire but I'm really not I just
genuinely enjoy sleeping in this and I
know it's giving pick me energy but it
was telling Claude that I think people
that make fun of other people's outfits
to go to sleep in they're the pikmi
girls Shannon was trying to like deflect
the pick me energy from her to me it's
not gonna [__] happen Shannon so she
Shannon is going to join me for the past
five today which is so exciting because
I heard you have a very hot take on
Sophia Richie's wedding coming for
everyone yeah sorry in advance um but
before we do that let's catch up with
Shannon it's been a while since you've
been on the toast because you're
literally never in New York because you
have a new boyfriend and it's not me
it's James and he lives in London and
you're always in London you guys are
always doing fabulous things without me
and I just want to know why Amanda needs
to invite you next time Manon needs to
invite me you're welcome to come listen
we're about to have some QT together
some quality time here some quality time
in Nashville for Taylor Swift yes like
we're just gonna have a lot of time
together but I agree I need to get back
to New York
um I miss New York although I will say
London is a lot like New York I'm not
gonna lie so I feel like it's there but
you're not there so it's not the same
when I was asking people on my social
media for questions for you every single
person just wants to know if you're
moving to London like what's the plan
your boyfriend lives in London you guys
are so in love it's been almost a year
now right yeah almost a year which is
crazy because I came on the toast when
we had just met we had met like two
weeks prior you and James met like
around this time that like you and I'm
at
we just started getting close yeah we
100 started hanging out like a month
before I met James yeah that's really
wow all the good things came into my
life at once so true wow that's actually
really sweet the universe is just
looking out okay so basically everyone
asked that question which I don't know
like I guess it makes sense because all
people that are asking me live in
America and they always see me in London
so they're like are you moving there but
like what's the plan so he's moving to
America okay so there's like you're not
going he's in the middle of his Visa
process I would eventually move to
London I have no problem with that like
I love London I really do it's very much
like New York so in the sense that like
there's not a lot of space it's pretty
like it's bustling City Metropolis yeah
which is really fun and I love that
James has lived in London his entire
life born and raised so he just he's not
from like a town outside of London and
England he's like from London and so
anyways I think he quite likes the idea
of an adventure in America and I'm
building a house so I'm [__] staying
put Shawty I can't believe you're
building a house you're such a grown-up
wow it's crazy that was also bunch of
questions we got for you you've been
sharing like your house building process
on social media which is just like
making me green with NBA you know
um and you've also been sharing how like
you've been in like you're saving money
era because you obviously had to put
down money in a house it's so expensive
you're building from scratch right yeah
it's just really crazy because like I'm
not a responsible person with money I
never have been I'm still like on the
cusp you could say like I'm every day
fighting with myself in the mirror being
like you're such a dumb [__] stop doing
that right right because I like you know
don't need to be spending crazy amounts
of money on stupid things like a Prada
bolo tie but it's just so cute did you
get it I've already had it I got it two
Christmases ago it's where actually
affectionately my um sister's wife told
me and I quote you're really running out
of [__] to buy yourself let me ask you a
question what are your thoughts on like
wearing fakes because like a Prada bolo
tie you'll probably only wear a
stagecoach like I don't know I feel like
in a situation like that get the fake
one I live in Nashville so I've actually
worn it a bit but I will say I I
understand fakes for like novelty items
like that yeah like there's is like
anything that's like um like Louis
Vuitton came out with that plastic
thingy where it was like see-through
plastic whatever I'm like okay like it's
literally plastic I know what you're
talking about like the see-through
Devils yeah I don't know I get it in
some cases but I also I guess I've just
I wore fakes all the time whenever I was
in like my early 20s I actually should
have saved the 300 I was spending on a
fake and just like saved up for a real
one but I really try not to wear fakes
because one they just break and there's
nothing more embarrassing I've been in
an airport when I was 21 I'll never
forget I was in an airport I called my
mom like why did I call my mom like
[__] go buy a new bag like I was like
what do I do she was like a [__] go buy
a new bag but I um I was carrying a
Louis duffel and it split down the
middle I'm talking it was literally it
was fake
split down the middle all my stuff came
out and then I ran as quickly as I could
I like was like wrapping it up and ran
into the whatever store like gift shop
bought a bag and then I asked the lady
to throw away the ripped Louis duffel
and she looked at me like I was out of
my mind she's like oh no and I had to
look at her and be like it's fake bye I
gotta go oh that's humiliated it was it
really it really triggered me so like I
don't really buy fakes that often no and
then I feel like once you buy a fake it
kind of
can create doubt in like about your
other [__] yeah it's like well if that's
fake everything is 100 but I did I don't
I actually don't currently own any fakes
but um there was this product beach bag
oh I was telling you about this so James
mother actually and I had this
conversation and I have that product
each bag and you messaged me being like
should I get this I want it so bad it's
so bad but it's like so pricey for like
a [__] beach I'll tell you what this
beach bag is it's a [__] beach bag it
literally is a beach bag that says prod
on it and I bought it it was a
transparently it was 1200 and I wish I
hadn't done that because in that
instance I only use it when I go to the
beach of course thrusted into the sand
and I wish I would have gotten a fake
and his mom and I were having this
conversation because his mom is like
very bougie very like like very just
chic you know Posh Londoner and she was
talking about fake bags and she's like
yeah like her and her friends have these
conversations and she's like you know I
I don't really get fakes but like
something I would never get is like that
Prada Beach guy I was like Ugh me either
no like I really want that bag but
honestly it's so pricey and I couldn't
wrap my head around it I guess the first
time in my life I'm like you know what
fake fake get the fake I honestly I kind
of want to you fraudulent to her if you
guys see me walking around with a Prada
beach bag just like no it's not real
it's fake unless you're smart that's
[__] real then oh that's true unless
um so Shannon is going to join me for
the Fast Five I'm excited we actually
have a lot of good stories and it's our
final episode of the week thanks for
sticking with us this week you guys
Jackie is back on Monday
um she'll be in studio with me and I
appreciate you know all the support for
all the guest co-hosts and we're we're
going out with a bang with Shannon
couldn't agree more today's episode is
brought to you by the real real the real
real is the largest and most trusted
source for luxury Consignment you'll
find everything from Gucci Prada Hermes
stodd so much more and it's all for up
to 90 off the retail price so it's more
it's for a more sustainable future the
real real is the best place to shop let
me tell you so many of my most fabulous
items this Fendi dress I've been
sporting for like a couple of weeks from
the real real earrings literally so many
things in my closet are from the real
real I've been shopping there forever
and it's so great to now be partnering
thank with them for the toast they have
a really rigorous authentication process
so they have hundreds of In-House luxury
brand experts GIA certified gemologists
brand authenticators and specialized Ai
and machine learning technology to
inspect authenticate price and list
thousands of items a day so I have a new
pair of diamond earrings that I actually
just invested in for myself and I trust
the real real I got them from the real
real I got all the paperwork they are
really the best when it comes to
authenticating and you can buy knowing
that your stuff is going to be legit and
you can feel good about spending that
money and if you want to consign stuff I
have sold stuff to the real real they
offer a full service experience from
free virtual appointments at home
pickups to direct shipping and drop-off
services at their retail locations so
like I said I can sign a lot of my stuff
stuff that I no longer wear and it's
nice to just get money back and they
make it so easy so visit the
realreal.com use code toast at checkout
for 20 off that's the realreal.com use
code toast for 20 off terms apply and as
Jackie O would say I think it's time to
invest invest in you girlfriend today's
episode is also brought to you by modern
fertility for a lot of us the start of
the New Year feels like the right time
to schedule doctor's appointments and
check in with where you're at
health-wise but what about your
reproductive Health if you've been a fan
of planning ahead like we have like
scheduling trips months in advance and
you've never thought much about having
kids as to when you're going to have
them check out modern fertility modern
fertility was created as an easy and
affordable way to test your fertility
hormones at home with a simple finger
prick you'll mail it in with a prepaid
label and you'll get your personalized
results within six business days you'll
get insight into your hormone levels
like your ovarian reserve which is
basically how many more or fewer eggs
you have than the average woman your age
and other important factors that can
impact your fertility the results go
deep into what every hormone means and
you can also download the results to
review with your doctor for next steps
traditional hormone testing at a
fertility clinic can cost over six
hundred dollars but modern fertility
tests the same general set of hormones
for only 179 dollars plus if you go to
modernfertility.com toast you can get 20
off your test plus you can get
reimbursed for the test through your f
FSA or your HSA if you want kids today
or maybe one day in the future
clinically sound information about your
body can help you make the decision
that's right for you
right now modern fertility is offering
our listeners 20 off the test when you
go to modernfertility.com toast the test
is already real really affordable plus
our 20 off it is a real deal your test
will cost 159 dollars that is a fraction
of what it would cost at a clinic so get
that 20 off your fertility test when you
go to modernfertility.com toast that's
modernfertility.com toast all right
Shannon are you ready for the fast five
stories that you need to know I'm so
ready
all right our first story of the day we
got the new Kardashians trailer oh God
it was good sometimes it's over hyped
this one was well we don't know if it's
going to be over hyped yet because it
hasn't come out yet I will say it did
look very good it looks like she talks
about Kanye it looks like they talk
about the beauty standards that they're
setting it looks like there's a big
drama there's been a lot of whispers
about what's going on between Courtney
and Kim they're like people think
Courtney and Kim aren't speaking to one
another really and they haven't been for
a while and this whole trailer debacle
with the wedding kind of adds fuel to
that fire yeah so I meant it might be
over hyped because sometimes you get
these trailers and people like did you
see the new trailer I'm like yeah I look
the same as they all did this one looks
like you're right like it has some
serious substance
some serious teeth so Kim is a crying in
the trailer a bunch a lot of people
think she's crying over Pete I don't
think she's crying over peace I do not
think that I think she's crying over
Kanye it must be that I forget about
that time because it was like kind of a
long time ago and so much has happened
since then but when he was just like
acting a fool and she's like in this
tough position it's like the father of
her kids and she obviously would never
want to speak ill of him but like he was
making it so hard I totally forgot about
that time and I like there's nothing I
respect more than a mom who knows that
her the father of her children is doing
wrong things but is doing the right
thing by not like really trying to make
that decision for her kids and and
really just like she said a thing in the
trailer she says I stay silent so that
for all I do all this for my kids no I
have so much respect for it and I've
never once held it against her anything
Kanye did because we all know how Kanye
is and we know like their relationship
and and we know how like much of a
invested and protective mother she is so
that never once bothered me she's also
never jumped to his defense in a way
that maybe be like shut up yeah why are
you defending him right now she's never
done that no she just honestly I think
the best thing she can do is stay silent
yeah so this trailer actually does look
very good
um for me
I am like gooped and gagged over this
Courtney Kim thing like that's what I
need to I need more information I I
rarely say this but when I say I need it
it was like this with the VPR drama like
I needed to know more about the Tom and
Rachel Saga yeah this is something I was
in the car I was literally in the car
and I was like so Margo you had gone in
to get your um that tried to kill me
R.I.P um and I was like okay so Margaret
a question is are they saying that Kim
basically did her which I'm gonna be
honest one of my favorite most recent
things that Kim Kardashian has done was
the Dolce it was iconic I thought she
looked fabulous I love the way her hair
was I loved the outfits I loved her
eating spaghetti I loved everything
about it and I'm like wait oh my gosh I
didn't put two and two together that was
because Courtney's whole entire wedding
was Dolce Gabbana in Italy I know and I
have to see how it plays out but I am
more inclined here to take Kim's side
really yeah because first of all like
the girls having any sort of
relationship with any fashion house
is all Kim's doing like Fair they were
like Sears they were low budget she
couldn't get arrested then she got
invited to the mech LS Kanye's plus one
and she worked her whole life she works
tirelessly to be accepted by like upper
echelon fashion people true and they're
in this place now we're like yeah she's
the face of Balenciaga she's a campaign
with Dolce they all go to the Met Gala
they are that because of Kim so you know
what I don't know if Courtney's mad that
like at I think maybe at her wedding Kim
started
the trials to like schmooze with the
Dolce people I don't know what the
timeline of events is but like I don't
know am I crazy to say like I don't
think it's that bad well I'm gonna be
very kind on Kylie in the trailer right
now and say I see both sides yeah that
was so kind of like that was so and they
were like I see both sides I'm like you
too pick up [__] side um I [__]
hate people at home if you what do you
stand for yeah nothing if you stand for
what never mind if you don't stand for
anything you stand for nothing no you'll
fall for if you don't stand for anything
you'll fall for wait if you stand for
nothing you'll fall for everything
nailed it that was it question
um okay so everyone in their car listen
to this is like these morons um so I'm
going to say though I'm not going to
take both sides I'm going to say I
actually kind of see Courtney's side a
little bit because like couldn't Kim
have just made those connections and
then been like hey after her wedding
like we're gonna do this because I'm
pretty sure the timeline was kind of
crazy but the Dolce thing with Kim did
come out way after the wedding oh really
yeah it was well then I need to see this
play out I need to see the timeline
you're right the timeline is everything
and sister Dynamics can be like touching
I died though when Kim was like I don't
know why she's upset I made sure that
they didn't put me in anything that she
wore in her wedding I was like Kim at
the least yeah it's not fair to judge
the whole situation based off the
trailer but like this actually does look
really good and they haven't been
um excited excited just because they've
been very low-key recently
um but there is a lot that they need to
address there's kind of been like a
crazy year for them and the one thing
that I didn't see in the trailer that I
was really hoping to to hear from in the
trailer was the Balenciaga Saga Valencia
Saga the blends to Saga I don't know how
they can avoid that but it seems really
they bring it up maybe they just didn't
want to put it in the trailer but surely
they bring it up you think I don't know
maybe they're just like we're not going
to touch this they don't want to give it
a tint like give Balenciaga more
attention I don't know I don't know
either but Kim has been like wearing
full Balenciaga looks really yeah like
very I haven't seen that yeah I know
it's like very understated but she has
been wearing it I think she still has
some sort of relationship with the brand
I myself have to shelf multiple sweaters
well you know I was actually in a store
recently that sells like a bunch of
designer items and we were like walking
through the different sections and we
walked through the Balenciaga section
and I was like by the way has anyone
been shopping here and they're like yeah
actually I every time I go buy a
Balenciaga store it's always empty and I
feel like I can't imagine the employees
must be closer than ever they're always
in a little circle and they're all
there's no one to talk to they're always
chatting it up and I thought that I bet
this is the only like good that might
have come out of this has been that
they've really created a family
friendship great friendships within the
Balenciaga employee Community I don't
know because they're only all just
talking [__] each other no it's true
every time I drive past the store I also
like looking I have not seen a single
Shopper in there in months I have I
don't know when I'll wear if I'll ever
wear it again but I just like still look
at it and like I still like go like so I
haven't put any on when the trailer
first opened and then like turned my
stuff yeah I know everyone's like burn
it and I was like well it paid clothing
you paid for it I don't I just wouldn't
burn anything that I owned I would just
like either give it away or like just
let it sit there I would either just
like let it sit there in a box I don't I
just don't think I would ever take fire
to like no the thing about the trailers
everyone's like oh my God she's talking
about Pete because they opened the
trailer with like the relationship and
the way I don't care like Not only was
it so long ago like Pete's had two
girlfriends since then like I just I
forget that that was even a thing and it
was so long ago I'm like oh are they
really trying to give us this [__]
but then there was so much more tea in
the trailer yeah but I was like this is
it really it was like a blip on her
radar like we're like oh it's a fun
little moment like we we all I don't
think anything happened with their
ending either other than he had to get
some tattoos covered up and she was
probably just like it's not you it's me
I gotta go right it's probably like okay
bye him right right right right it was
just meh yeah I just I I'm not I don't
know what they're gonna tell us that
we're gonna be shocked by when it comes
to their split I agree no there's a lot
of interesting stuff about Kanye there's
a lot of interesting stuff about
whatever's going on with the wedding and
the Dolce and oh and Kylie said that
thing about the she was like we really
need to um talk about our families
um the decisions we make that like
impact the beauty standard we set yeah
and she was like I don't want my
daughters to do the same things that I
did but I'm like curious to see if she's
gonna be like I don't want my daughters
to like look in the mirror and like
think that they look big one day I want
to tell them they're beautiful I'm gonna
be like Kylie talk about like what you
did to your face your butt your boobs
you're like what are you talking about
it's like unless they go full in to have
this conversation and I don't I do not
and I think I'm unique in this I do not
hold them responsible for any decisions
they make about their bodies and how it
impacts culture like I think that's like
an unfair burden to put on someone and I
have this conversation all the time and
I know a lot of people don't agree with
me and that's fine but so I don't need
them to have this conversation I think a
lot of people do they're like finally
they're talking about I don't need them
to have this conversation but if they're
going to have it they have to go balls
to the wall like 100 transparent and I
don't think they don't owe us that
either so I don't think they are okay so
I'm actually not just saying this to
agree with you for real for real I
genuinely I think that like I agree in
the sense that everyone's doing the same
[__] to their body that they are and I
don't know if everyone is doing it
because they want to look at Kardashian
right I think actually if you like went
down to Miami you would see that
everyone was doing this before the
Kardashians yeah they're gonna do it
after the Kardashians the Kardashians
are just seen on a much larger scale and
a much larger stage so like I agree in
the sense that it's not the Kardashian
effect it's like the genre and era we're
in effect but here's the thing even if
it is the Kardashian effect I don't
really feel like that's their problem
because they are you know people with
bodily autonomy they should be able to
make whatever decisions they want to
gain weight they want to lose weight
they want to get plastic surgery they
want to do something like they should be
able to make decisions about their
bodies without having to worry about how
it affects the culture like yeah that's
a huge way to carry that is a burden I
just I agree with you I hope that not
like yeah like everyone's beautiful from
the inside out I'm like if you're gonna
[__] talk about it talk about it
don't do it just to have a like moment
for Kylie's segment on the show like I
want it to be like good it has to be
like legit authentic conversation and
and I don't think it will be so I think
they should just ignore it honestly yeah
I just cut Kylie scenes no she's always
so sweet Kylie really is like so
interesting and so fabulous she just
gives nothing to the show I think she
does it to protect her piece which I
totally understand but like come on she
wants to be like like out of the I don't
even think she wants to be out of the
spotlight but I think she just all every
time I see her she's like bringing
clothes over to Chloe or she's like
putting her hand on someone's back being
like it's gonna be okay she's like a
sounding board yeah she's really sweet
and wonderful but I'm like I think like
you know
I want more from her I'm oh wait she but
Kylie always leaves us wanting more and
maybe that's why I feel like of all of
them she's really not like super
Overexposed she's low-key like very
private yeah sometimes it feels like
with the main girls like it's like a
little bit too much and and it's like a
lot of exposure but I don't feel that
way with Kylie no I wish she would do
more I wish she would come back I wish
you would I wish you would
um okay our next story uh we're talking
about Sophia Grange excuse me is
honeymoon
um oh where's she going well so she has
been posting a bunch of stuff with
Elliot the newlyweds enjoyed a romantic
bike ride in the first glimpse of their
vacation since tying the knot in the
south of France last weekend the 24 year
old bride did not reveal the location of
her and Elliot's getaway she posted
several Instagram story photos of their
tropical trip on Thursday you haven't
figured it out no and you know what I
was looking and I'm so curious it looks
like Maldives Fiji it's very tropical
it's white sand oh my God I would think
for sure the internet's loose of the
world would be like that palm tree on
the left with the branch we saw that in
2007 no Mumbai these upper echelon like
actual like 0.01 they go to like these
private islands like this is not a hotel
any of us have ever been to right I my
first thought was like where the [__] is
this maybe like Lionel's friend has an
island you know I could see that I need
I don't know where it is but I just
wanted to use this story as one she
looks great so happy oh and you were
showing me
um a tick tock that pointed out it
looked like Sophia Richie got her breast
implants removed oh yeah I saw that it
was like when she was a little spot
people were comparing her pictures um in
a bikini with her husband now
um to old pictures of her in bikinis
where she had clearly had implants and
it does it looks like she got them taken
out she looks much more natural and
small and I think she looks great I
think they just like suit her body
better yeah I thought that was
interesting teeny tiny little tot that
like didn't need like some knockers well
this honeymoon story is like not that
interesting but I did want to use it as
a sounding board because I know Shannon
has like a diatribe to deliver about
Sophia Richie's wedding so oh my God I
don't I just like genuinely in the car I
was like this might be hot take but like
I just wasn't that blown away I think
like the internet like grasps onto
something and then everyone's like oh my
God are you watching are you watching it
and I was like I do think that like some
of her like Chanel Luke's were like
really like classy and stunning but I
just wasn't I didn't understand why we
were so so so so so engulfed with it
like I know everyone's like so I'm like
seeing tick tocks it's like
um old money is back old money I'm like
well not of us [__] have old money
and a lot of us have spent our new money
on a product bolo ties and I don't want
old money to come back in style
literally no because I am like really
trashy and obvious but I do think that
um it was just a bit overhyped in the
sense that like I'm not discrediting her
love she looked really happy she looked
like I really do love the era of like
the comparison with her and her and
Scott like I'm so much happier for her
and this is so much more like mature and
like it's more pulled back it seems more
her it seems more genuine even when she
was a Scott she almost looked so out of
place in her little like sparkly pink
jumpsuits I'm like you don't meant to be
here no actually do you remember she
used to date Justin Bieber yeah of
course so she is giving Haley Bieber in
the sense that like she's always been
that esque so like I'm really happy for
her I just didn't think the wedding was
that [__] cool the only thing I
thought was cool is when Charlotte
played lifestyle that rich in the famous
famous rich people dancing to it I was
like iconic so good but let me explain I
think why there's like this Obsession
and I think it's like it was a
culmination of like yeah it was a
beautiful wedding it was south of France
it was very expensive all that yada yada
but it was a culmination of that plus
like the element of her being a nepo
baby but in a really like not annoying
way like Fair Richie is so legendary and
then there's Nicole Richie and then
there's Nicole Richie's husband and then
there's Nicole Richie's husband's
brother and Cameron's husband's
brother's wife Cameron Diaz and then
Paris was there and it was like Paris
and Nicole there were so many elements
of Pop Culture that's really true like a
Melting Pot and then Sophia just like
came out of the woodwork as this like it
girl like this she was so everything she
did was like so pulled back and so
classy and and tasteful and not in like
an overt money kind of way which it
could have been because totally he her
husband is richer than her really his
her husband his dad is the chairman of
Universal Music Group which is like he's
the chairman these and his oh and his
mom and dad are a lady and a what's the
title that goes with a lady you would
know you're British now I don't know an
Earl no it's a certain lady okay like
they're they're that Aristocrat like
okay there there's a lot in this wedding
once you start to unpack that I think is
where the fascination okay because the
wedding itself was absolutely gorgeous
but it wasn't unlike a wedding we've
ever seen from a celebrity in terms of
like the flowers and [__] but just like
the people and all the different details
about everyone there and what we knew
about them It came it ended up being
extremely fascinating okay you know what
a mistake I'll flip you flip I'll flip
you can stand your ground I just I guess
I kept getting um targeted for all the
outfit things and everyone's like
everyone was like I'm gagging I'm dead
and I was like okay it's a lace dress
like it's okay it's beautiful but like I
just don't get the hype with like this
Chanel like I'm like okay but now that
you've explained it in that way I
understand why people wanted the ins and
outs and I wish I had dug deeper I would
have been maybe more fascinated but wait
I also do agree with you like the way
people just like get gagged over things
on social media they're like not that
gag worthy but they do it just to like
it's like we were talking about this
this morning like when Beauty gurus like
on social media try foundations and they
put like a DOT of the foundation on
their face they're like
and they stopped gonna die like the
coverage like there's just like a
sensationalized like trend on social
media where it's like we have to be so
[__] breathless yeah over everything
it's a calm the phone it's a [__]
brown-looked eyeliner like the girl like
does a little wing and she's like look
are you saying that she's like are you
seeing that guys look okay I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm like you don't be sorry sis
it's [__] brown liquid eyeliner no
it's okay that I agree with in terms of
like the way people were reacting and
such like that's the tick tocks I was
targeted by the way I agree with you so
we both agree with each other okay we're
Stakes we'll float today's episode is
brought to you by Urban stems Urban
stems delivers modern bouquets and
stylish plants next day and Nationwide
their Mother's Day collection is curated
with love and adoration in mind every
bouquet is designed in-house and it's on
Trend every delivery includes a
personalized note to your recipient
softly designed packaging and 100
happiness guaranteed let me tell you how
someone I work with whenever they're
sending me flowers has always like for
years used Urban stems and then I
started to copy them because I'm
constantly sending people flowers you
know I'm very generous like that
congratulations feel better Happy
anniversaries you know good luck
whatever I'm sending and I use urban
stems all the time it's so easy I love
because I'm like a last minute Queen
they do next day delivery it's really
efficient it's really fast and they have
really really beautiful beautiful
designs you can shop by color by price
range and even by flower type on their
website so you'll take your pick from a
variety of bouquets
plants gifts and floral subscription
options are available too and with
Mother's Day coming up you know you got
to get on the flowers this is your
reminder don't be the bad kid it's on
Sunday May 14th be sure to order in time
and use code toast for 15 off your
purchase at urbanstems.com again that's
code toast for 15 off your purchase at
urbanstems.com that's
u-r-b-a-n-s-t-e-m-s.com don't be the
least favorite child be the best child
get ahead of your delivery get something
gorgeous from Urban stems and again use
code toast for 15 off your purchase
today's episode is brought to you by
fast growing trees breathe some life
into your own backyard with
fastgrowingtrees.com this spring from
shade to fresh fruit to privacy and
natural beauty let fastgrowingtrees.com
help you plant your dream garden with
their expert advice and fast reliable
shipping you guys know Miss Jackie O is
obsessed with her yard she went wild on
fastgrowingtreats.com she found such
gorgeous gorgeous trees that are perfect
for her environment you know she lives
in Florida so fastgrowingtrees.com they
are the expert they know exactly what is
right for her climate for her area
fastgrowingtrees.com's plant experts
curate thousands of easy to grow plant
shrub and tree varieties for your unique
climate Meyer lemons to Evergreens and
everything in between happy plants happy
home right but sometimes it's hard to
know which plants will do best but with
fastgoingtrees.com you get customized
recommendations based on your specific
needs that's exactly what Jackie did
plus their plant experts are always
available to help keep your plants
growing healthy throughout the season
and Beyond so no more waiting in long
lines and hauling heavy plants around
with fastgardingtrees.com you order
online and your plants arrive at your
door in just a few days and their 30 day
alive and Thrive guarantee you know that
everything will look great fresh out of
the box join the over 1.5 million happy
fast growing trees customers go to
fastgrowingtrees.com toast now you'll
get 15 off your entire order that's 15
off your entire order when you go to
fastgrowingtrees.com
t-o-a-s-t have a gorgeous yard get into
gardening you know spring has sprung
spring is upon us don't forget to go to
fastgrowingtrees.com toast
um all right speaking uh we were just
starting my Paris Hilton I was
completely shocked to learn that Paris
Hilton is going to attend the Met Gala
for the first time ever
did you know that she had never gone no
wait hold on that I can't be that's true
according to Patient First time she's
invited the first time she decided to go
that's a good question so Paris Hilton
is finally headed to the Met Gala the
heiress DJ and author will attend
Fashion's biggest night for the first
time ever this year page six style has
confirmed TMZ was the first to report
that Paris would be attending sources
told the outlet that Hilton scored a
coveted invite from Vogue and the
designer of her look for the event
details which are still under wrapped so
we don't know which designer she's going
to be going with but she was famously
friends with the late designer Carl
Lagerfeld whose life and work are the
theme of this year's met Galley
Institute so I wonder why that's why she
was invited because actually the more
you were saying it the more I was like
actually Paris Hilton doesn't give me
Met Gala and they are pretty picky with
their list like they are they're weird
still but then you know what they're
also weird about they'll do like who's
ever super super popular in the moment
like I actually of course I don't think
like this would really happen this year
but like they're the kind of people that
would invite Alex Earl to the Met gal
because she's having such a moment oh my
God if Alex Earl goes to the Met Gala
will die of joy that I would be so happy
right she would just be so thrilled
she'd just be there smiling she's so
grateful she she'd post a tick tock
being like how am I here and we'd be
like you're [__] Alex Earl I don't
even feel like that's that crazy I feel
like she could go she's seeing Charlie
went that's what I'm saying so like I
think no but I'm sorry the fact that
like Dixie and Charlie went and like
James Charles has went and like
nikkietutorials so many influencers when
like Paris was like really like at the
she was like the spearhead or a pioneer
of like influencer movement in terms of
like not being famous for like a
particular trade and skill she really
like was a huge part I mean if you saw
the American meme documentary like she
really is a pioneer of like the
influencer age and for her to have not
ever been is actually crazy when they've
now opened they've since opened up to
influence right I think maybe they were
just waiting for her Resurgence because
she has had such a Resurgence lately
yeah Kyle's actually his background of
his screen as long as I've known him on
his phone has been that picture
iconically of Paris Hilton that swearing
a shirt that says stop being poor I love
that that photo okay but you know that
photo's photoshopped no it doesn't say
that t-shirt doesn't say stop being poor
in real life what's it say something
dumb like oh my God yeah I have to tell
Kyle
um but what's also interesting is that
Nikki Hilton has attended the Met Ball
just one time in 2001. as a guest of
someone I guess Nikki Hilton is like
very fashion girly she's not so much
like mainstream as Paris yeah she's very
like she goes to like fashion shows and
she's like the Valentino family oh I did
know that but I find that interesting
huh well I'm excited to see her look I
really can't wait I think it's gonna be
slipping I think it's gonna be slipping
too I'm just like I'm I'm gooped and
gagged to know that she's never been
invited or she's never attended
my stomach's making the craziest noises
and I keep wondering if the mic is
picking it up so if you guys have been
hearing some rumbling and Grumble and
it's actually not Claude turdy mcgloo
it's me by the way I thought you were
gonna say like you might have caught
what I had but my what I had was
contagious no no
um okay our fourth story is a little
Chance the Rapper news did you see that
video going viral Chance the Rapper like
twerking twerked on ding yes but I have
I I where was he at again
uh some I think some sort of an island
Jamaica okay so culturally that's how
they dance I know it is like not like I
think that is totally what they do
normally and it's not anything I mean I
know you're gonna look and think what do
you mean you know from like American
culture but I think that's truly like
it's like if you had gone and seen
someone doing salsa with someone that
wasn't their husband or wife and they'd
be like looking really sexual and sexy
but like that's how Salsa's intended to
be danced Jamaicans just genuinely that
is how they dance I completely agree I
think it's really common at a lot of
those Carnival festivals that they do on
the islands and they do in Brazil but
his wife has now posted a cryptic 12
quote after that dance went viral so
well they're super super religious so
are you joking Chance the Rapper are you
a joke I didn't know that I'm not oh my
God he all like like immensely so
immensely I want to say this could be so
inaccurate I want to say he doesn't cuss
in his wraps
I could be so wrong he but he and his
wife are very very very Christian
that could be such a lie it could be
lying but like he's there he like
they're very religious so about a week
after he went viral for dancing
inappropriately with another woman his
wife Kristen Corley shared a cryptic
message on her Instagram she posted an
excerpt from Maya Angelou's essay called
home which discusses how most people
never mature it says this most people
don't grow up it's too damn difficult
what happens is most people get older
that's the truth of it oh they honor
their credit cards they find parking
spaces they have the nerve to have
children but they don't grow up not
really they just get older oh wow so
Maya Angelou then continues but to grow
up costs the earth the earth it means
you take responsibility for the time you
take up to the space you occupy it's
serious business so his wife highlighted
that answer what a quote by the way Maya
Angelou like what a what a quote and she
captioned the post I hope one day we all
choose to grow up oh no what do you
think maybe she's talking about all of
us I don't know that's a really good but
no I just Googled it just to make sure I
wasn't wrong not about the cussing but
Chance the Rapper considers himself a
Christian rapper he doesn't even know he
that that's why him and Justin Bieber
were like all up and up and yeah they
were all about songs
[Music]
yeah yeah Chance the Rapper and Justin
Bieber you're right you're right exactly
okay anyways oh so there's like this is
a layered story yeah but I will say I
mean to be fair even you know culture
aside he was getting his his Bing Bong
absolutely rammed against I want to say
culture or not there was some penis and
vagina like yeah that was that's the he
wasn't being recorded secretly he said
look at the camera like he knows fair so
I don't know but this I think it very
sneaky Vibes it's a cryptic quote yeah
wow okay I'm very I'm interested to see
how that plays out I hope they you know
stick it out I know they're also very
private I think a lot of people didn't
even know he had a wife and two kids oh
really I feel like that's also not true
because he openly talks about how much
he loves his family because he's like
super Christian rapper I mean I didn't
know that and I really like Chance the
Rapper and I said I honestly I saw the
video and I didn't think it was that
crazy like I get it I know that that's
like a thing a tradition that's done
culturally yeah I just didn't it looked
more like a joke like like he was like
oh oh my goodness what's happening it
looked like one of those things he
wasn't like oh yeah loving this oh yeah
he wasn't giving that Vibe yeah no he
wasn't like giving and the fact that it
wasn't like filmed sneaky from the side
like everyone I call it chance rapper I
don't know I choose to see the good in
people me too um is your fifth Story
going to be about Glenn Powell no but
can we talk about it please I mean we've
been talking about it all week oh oh
okay never mind no no I want to hear
what you have to say no I just I didn't
know um even though uh I believe someone
from Sydney's team like yesterday spoke
to Alex being like she's still very much
engaged to this guy yeah I think that
they're doing a classic actually did
Matthew McConaughey and um Kate Hudson
ever actually did in real life I think
they might have but what you're
referring to we like to call the um oh
hold on me and Jackie we're just talking
about this guys help me you guys are
probably screaming at your phones wait I
need silence for one second
who just did this and like we all went
oh Lady Gaga and yeah whatever I just
think like they're doing that but we
don't if you guys have already we don't
talk about the only thing I want to talk
about is like holy [__] I didn't not
realize how hot he is
I am absolutely engulfed in whatever
like if he becomes the next like rom-com
man of Our Generation I'm here for it I
find him to be absolutely Stellar
looking yeah completely agree Shannon
Rob's really hot and I actually think
this whole Scandal which is what I've
been saying all week is that it's very
good for him because people don't think
about him a lot like
Top Gun um that Zoe Deutsch Netflix
rom-com that people like what's it
called I don't know the setup I've never
set it up or something I've never seen
it um he has like a he's a following but
this is definitely gonna catapult him to
the next level and honestly what would
really catapult him to the next level is
if they really just started dating yeah
that and if the movie's good I would
love to see the movie Yes okay but no
our fifth and final story is James
Corden last night was his his Farewell
to The Late Late Show oh really yeah I
saw a bunch of clips of like the
sketches that did that seemed really
cute and funny Harry Styles was there
they actually did this sketch that I
thought was hilarious with all the other
late night co-hosts Seth Meyers Jimmy
Kimmel Jimmy Fallon Stephen Colbert and
James Corden oh wow it was hysterical
and I will say like James Corden has had
a rough year I feel like he became like
it's like Anne Hathaway syndrome like
you get so popular that you
automatically become hated for like
seemingly nothing
um
but I don't know I actually do like him
well we know that my Affinity in life is
Balthazar New York so oh yeah what were
your thoughts on his him allegedly being
the most hated man in Balthazar
restaurant I mean I just couldn't care
[__] less like I was just like okay
I'm sure he was a dick like I don't know
like so you don't have to but it was
just funny the guy what's his name Kevin
yeah he's like you are no longer ever
allowed in my restaurant and then he
made it lame because he kept going back
and forth being like never mind he
called me never mind he's not allowed
never mind this I'm like okay he was
watching like a fool like it was so
crazy I didn't I just thought it was
like funny about the things he said
James Corden complained about but I just
like I don't really I'm so nice to ever
in a restaurant I can't imagine I'll
ever get to a place in my life where I
won't be so rude yeah but like I mean I
don't know I just don't think anyone can
ever be canceled for being mean to a
waiter that's what Jackie and I's take
were was so it's just been like a bad
year for him and I feel like he's
probably looking forward to like being
off the show because he needs to like
get out of the headlines for a while
when you're like so in the media with
really like what else has happened other
than that though
um he every time he gets cast in
something everyone's like oh my God no
really cats I think he's in Wicked
everyone's just like enough
um he's just like he's everywhere all at
once and I think what happens in the
culture it's like this happened with
Anne Hathaway it's like she wasn't even
doing that much media but she would just
get in the media all the time people get
so annoyed with you they start to
[__] hate you yeah and it's like not
fair because you didn't do anything
wrong but people can't explain their
dislike for you you I feel like that
happened with Taylor Swift too yes of
course it happens to a few people I feel
like it happened to Chrissy Teigen many
years ago oh my God yeah she was just so
Overexposed and it wasn't even her doing
she wasn't doing interviews but we're
like just shut up everyone was I
actually felt that way about Chrissy
Teigen I was like enough she wasn't
doing it she wasn't coming to my house
being like read this about me it was
just it was BuzzFeed just writing [__]
up about her like yeah everyone and then
like E news which is always posting
about her and I was like shut up the
funny thing in the sketch last night was
like all the co all the hosts got
together and they were like well before
you leave we have to like split up your
ideas and everyone was like okay I want
carpool karaoke and then Jimmy Fallon
was like no I want carpool karaoke
another one I was like no I want carpool
karaoke and James corden's like you guys
I have more than one good idea like not
really not really no but it's true
carpool and and he's been in the news a
lot this week because carpool karaoke
was a segment they started with Adele
and this week he aired his final carpool
karaoke which he ended with Adele oh it
was really sweet oh I love that I know
I'm just like sad we never got a Taylor
Swift carpool karaoke me too damn anyone
who didn't do carpool karaoke like will
never yeah true wow everything that
Adele does kind of makes me want to cry
of like this like deep-rooted like
sweetness and love yeah she's really
like a nice person my friends convinced
she's like um like an alien or a psychic
or something she's like she just has so
much like passion and power with like
people's emotions yeah no like the
Chokehold she has everyone under is not
normal totally well Manning Manning you
did good thank you so much Claude for
having me those are the past five we've
just been staring at a golf course this
whole time but I know we're not even
looking at each other this is like kind
of the weirdest way I've ever podcasted
we're like laying in bed but she's fine
at podcasting about a million times but
we're not looking at each other we're
both looking at the window because the
view from my bedroom is really so
gorgeous
obviously oh yeah I did get the master
bedroom but that's because I was sick
and I want to say I did not ask for it I
was secretly hoping for it because
there's enough bedrooms per people so
like it was just you know and everyone
was like yeah Claudia can have it I was
like oh really this is crumbled I did
find it and booked the house you were
never knocking at the master and
rightfully so no really and I told the
primary bedroom sorry I said anyone can
sleep with me like no one wants to sleep
with me I'd like to sleep with people
how many times have I told you to get in
my bed for someone who said that I was
trying to [__] you in my negotiating you
have asked me to get in your bed like
three times she woke up and came into my
bed this morning I was like hey John
come inside and then she went to bed
with me last night I didn't want to
watch TV and then on my kitchen I didn't
want to get my bed and podcast maybe
we're both trying to [__] maybe yeah we
see each other
I love that first wow I cannot wait to
make so many tick tocks and absolutely
gag everyone with our outfits it's so
important to know it's 9 30 in the
morning and we literally will not be
leaving for the festival for eight hours
so early so I'm probably gonna have
diarrhea again if I'm being honest and
maybe take a nap I I too would like to
follow in your footsteps well guys
thanks so much for listening to the
toast the millennial Morning Show where
we deliver the first time stories they
need to know everybody so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available
standing in wickedly down did we are
hope you guys have a great weekend we
love you and we'll see you on Monday bye